hello my name is matthias from data tab
and in this short video i want to show
you how to calculate
paired t-test with data tab so first of
all with the data tab
punchnet afterwards
simply click on statistics calculator
and then choose the section t test
and anova if you want to calculate a prt
test
first you need to clear the table
and afterwards you can enter your own
data
i prepared example um
where to test whether the summer
holidays have an effect
on the physical fitness of students so
the question is
do the summer holidays have an effort
effect on the physical fitness of
statistics students
for this purpose a fitness test is
carried out
once before and once after the holidays
for 10 statistics students so for each
student
we have two measurement points
i have the data here in this table so
i simply
copied the data and paste the data
into the statistics calculator
afterwards i scroll down and simply
select the two variables
points before holidays and points after
holidays
now because the data are paired i simply
clicked
paired sample and
here i get the results for the paired
t-test
first of all i get the descriptive
statistics
so i have the mean value for both groups
the number of samples the standard
deviation
and so forth on and so forth and here we
also have zip box plot
afterwards you can see the results for
the paired t-test
you can see that the p-value also called
say
significance is 0.197
therefore the significance level or the
significance is higher
as five percent that means that no
significance
has that no difference is assumed
between these two groups
i hope you like this video and visit us
at datatep.net
thanks